We're not going to be able to study indepth
any of the architectural styles that we just discussed. However, I
want to at least discuss two representative examples of P2P
architectures. Because, these are systems that you probably used, or at
least, you used one of them. And, they will allow
me to highlight some interesting points. So, as we just mentioned,
P2P systems are decentralized resource sharing and discovery systems. And the
two systems that I want to discuss, and that are representative
of this kind of architectures, are Napster and Skype. And you may or
may not be familiar with Napster, but I'm pretty sure that you know Skype.